- Well I saw you posted
a photo of how you handle
(dog barks) spit up.
And I--
Oh sorry, my dog just barked
at my husband so apparently
he senses evil
- It's okay.
Our dog just might bark soon
- [Kelly] (laughs)
No sorry he keeps barking,
but no I saw this photo that you posted
and you're already just given up on shirts
cause like you've got vomit going
down the back of you. (laughs)
- You know what's funny
is someone asked me
that the other day.
They go, "do you ever wear
a shirt?" and I'm at home.
The answer is not most of the time
because I guess when I
work out at the house,
I don't workout with a shirt on
and then I don't shower
until seven o'clock at night
and I just kinda leave the shirt off.
Especially when I'm holding the baby
I mean there's no point in ruining
you know eight shirts during the day.
I think my wife changes about
17 times just from spit up so.
- Oh my gosh.
I gave up on nice things.
I just own black or white.
I'm just like whatever.
So I saw a video of showing you outdoors
while you're quarantining.
What were you doing in a tree?
Like I saw this video of
you like trying to swing
like it's Tarzan like what?
Who's that deal with that?
- [Thomas] We just moved into a new house
and we were kind of exploring outside
and my wife noticed this
vine hanging from the tree
and my kids were trying to swing on it.
And Lauren was like, "I use
to do that when I was little"
and she was like, "well let me go try it"
and I said, "how bout you
go let me try it first
just to make sure that it's like stable."
And so I like yanked on it a couple times
and it felt fine and
then like I went for it
and the limb just snapped in half
and I think I bruised my tailbone
and I'm really embarrassed that
Lauren caught that on video,
but you know that's
just what we do around.